did you see did you didn't trump say
yesterday that he was like nobody's
beating
covered like he's beaten at the doctor
said they couldn't believe how great his
body was at being coveted
so [ __ ] it's it's it's so insane now
that
it's almost now he's almost doing that
thing
and this is controversial i'm about to
say but and i know that a lot of people
get like [ __ ] you no
but to me i'm just talking about my
personal things i'm not saying i'm
voting for him i'm not
taking a political stand at all i'm just
saying because of his level of insanity
and how much how many times he said
things like
my no one's ever seen anybody be covered
like me he's becoming likable
to me because it's so crazy that i'm
almost like
i [ __ ] actually like this guy now
because he's out of his mind
yeah it's the same way yeah like i had a
i had a thing
where uh when i get off the elevator in
my building with my dog if she
has pooped and peed before the walk and
we've done the full cycle
if she hits for the cycle then i unclip
her on the elevator
and i'm like you can run because we live
at the end of the hall i'm like
go ahead have fun yeah and last night i
did it and she like did her little trot
and i was like oh cute and then she just
started
[ __ ] wigging out and just like
running all the way down the hall
yeah we're all the way back and at first
i was like no stop
smyrdle stop it and she's like running
around and then i started laughing
because i was like
yo you're insane yeah she's like look at
me and they're like
staring down the hallway and you're like
what are you doing she's stopping at it
like give me your
and that's how i feel with trump
sometimes i'm like you're making me
laugh because it's so
frustratingly insane so crazy but the
fact that he's like
i just i i kicked the [ __ ] out of calvin
yeah they show a video where he's like
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think you did it's he's the
ultimate guy of like dude i [ __ ] a
[ __ ] her
so good and then you talk her and she's
like hey like came
and then it was weird he like sucked his
thumb and you're like
what he's like i [ __ ] her i gave her a
second [ __ ]
yeah and then you asked him he's like
just [ __ ] lying ass [ __ ] yeah
so what what actually happened he's like
are you gonna believe her bro what are
you gay
yeah i don't know she said yeah you know
you pick a
yeah he's the kind of guy he's the kind
of guy he's the kind of guy like why
don't you come suck my dick and you're
like no i don't want to suck your dick
he's like what are you gay yeah
he tries to [ __ ] you into it dude
it's like one of those things too where
it's like trump is like the thing
and even kind of the world in general
it's like things have gotten at times
so bad and you like want things to be so
good that if you just let go
it's like it's so freeing like yes like
last week
like an idiot i have a five-year-old
daughter and a ten-year-old stepson and
i got
i got a new car and the inside of the
car is white leather
which is just like why would you do that
with children yeah but i got it and i
was like
i thought i pressed a different button
on the app when i ordered the car online
but it's got white leather now so what
can you do
and literally the first day i have the
new car
i go to pick up my daughter get her in
sits in the car she's like oh
dad i was like how was your day at
school and she's like i forgot to tell
you right before dismissal so like eight
minutes ago
she's like i pee-pee in my pants so i'm
like so are you sitting
in the car now full of urine and then i
feel it and it's piping hot piss
all over her stockings and i'm like just
let go
you just got white leather now there's a
piss stain on my
25 to 30 minute old car i ha i drove it
from the dealership
to pick up my daughter to surprise her
and there's a piss stay now in the car
immediately
and i could have gotten angry and be
like [ __ ]
but if you just let it go because if
that didn't happen i would still to this
day
a week later i've been like don't touch
my car don't get it don't get chocolate
yeah don't nick it don't do that don't
do that but now it's like there's
already a piss stain in it
yeah so it's over now i'm not gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of it but it's like
just relax things get dirty times are
bad
just relax that's kind of how i felt in
2016 when trump got elected and everyone
was like
it's the end and you're like well
there's nothing to do let go just let go
let go and he's gonna do a lot of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] yeah just let go
keep tabs and you know hopefully in four
years it's a little different and now
we're at the end we're like
you still just keep just stay let go
just like i'm trying to let go it's just
hard to like i don't know it's just
[ __ ]
it's hard to let go because my oxygen
left isn't dropping
feeling sick yeah it's like not letting
go off doing deep breathing but the
problem is when you tell me to leave
breathe i'm only getting 85
oxygen i feel like i feel like we were
gonna feel like we were in a pandemic
four years ago and i could just
yeah the thing is to think it's [ __ ]
i've been taking deep breathing and let
it go but no there's a respiratory all
this bug from the chinese it's for the
same petri dish
that's jackie chatted yeah i'm gonna now
i can't i can't breathe i'm gonna get
out i'm gonna get out of the hot tub i
wanna get out of the hot tub i'm gonna
faint
thank you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed the last video don't forget to
tell your friends
like subscribe and turn on notifications
[Music]